-Naomi, welcome back.
It is always great to see you.
I missed you.
-It's been a minute.
-It's been a minute, yeah.
-A long minute.
-How does it feel to be in
front of an audience?
-I mean, it's been
a while, and --
-Yes. It's the best!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy you came in person.
We really appreciate this
and coming to the show.
I recently saw a photo of
you and our pal Billy Crudup,
who we love, on the red carpet
of the SAG Awards.
There you guys are there.
And is this the first --
is this the first, like,
red carpet I think I've seen in
like 2 1/2 years or something.
-Definitely. It was nice to be
back and, you know,
get frocked up and everything.
-Yeah. Is that what they call --
-Frocked up?
Do you say that?
-I mean, the night is young.
Yeah, we can always --
We can get --
If you want to get --
We got time.
You want to get
frocked up tonight?
We can do it.
We've got champagne.
You guys want to get frocked up?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's do it.
♪♪
I guess that means "dressed up."
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah?
-Yes.
-Okay, yeah, of course.
-Put the frocks on.
-"Put the frocks" --
Okay, gotcha.
-Okay. And, yeah, it was nice.
It was a good night to be back
and see old friends
that you haven't seen for
a while and --
-It is, right?
-Yeah.
-You get to see everybody and
you go, "Oh, my gosh."
You don't realize how much --
How many people you miss
until you're in a room.
-It just, like, disappeared,
all that time,
and then there you are.
-Well, you've been to
so many award shows.
One of your movies,
"The Impossible," the --
I think it was 10 -- You got an
Oscar nomination for that.
That's ten years ago?
-Yeah.
-Is that possible?
-And I wanted to show
this picture,
'cause your son in the movie
was a man by the name of
Tom Holland.
-That's right.
-And --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, you've heard of him.
[ Laughs ]
-Wait. What was --
Did you have any idea
that he was going to be one of
the biggest stars
on the planet?
-I mean, I knew he had a future.
-Yeah.
-I could tell that he was
a brilliant actor.
He came with great
discipline and focus,
'cause he was an athlete.
And, you know, he was very
dedicated to doing that.
So, I knew he would be --
he would be good.
-Yeah.
-And then he also has a really
great, beautiful family,
who keep him grounded,
and -- and a raw talent, so --
-That's pretty cool.
-But I didn't really think,
"Oh, wow,
this guy's going to be in
'Spider-Man.'"
-Oh, that would've been --
Yeah, that would've been --
-That would have been
a far-fetched --
-That would have
been weird, like,
"This boy will be
Spider-Man one day."
Like, "Alright."
-Yes. I have a vision.
-"Get back to your
dressing room, take a nap, yeah.
You're a little
frocked up right now."
But he turned out great.
I love it.
And, obviously,
I love that movie.
You were telling me backstage,
and I did not --
I could not
guess this about you,
but you were --
You've turned into a car person.
-Well, inadvertently, yeah.
I never -- I mean, I love cars,
but I don't obsess over
how you choose them,
and, you know, I don't have,
like, a special brand that I --
you know, I'm attached to.
-No. But then you just recently
got a vehicle and you --
-My favorite car right --
Well, as of now.
But, yeah, it's a mom van.
I call it my Hot Wheels.
-Yeah. You got a minivan.
-I've got a minivan.
And you can do all kinds of
things with a minivan.
Did you know?
You can get frocked up in it!
-You can?
You can get frocked up
coming out of a minivan?
Tell me about the minivan,
'cause I am obsessed.
-Well, seven seats.
You can move furniture,
which I had to do
in the middle of the pandemic
by myself.
You can put the surfboards
in there.
It's great for the beach.
You can -- you can do
all kinds of things.
You can have all your friends,
and it just --
And you don't care.
-It's like a party van.
-And you don't, like --
-You don't care.
-My kids were embarrassed.
They were like,
"Mom, that is so not cool."
-Yeah. Your kids are teenagers.
-Yes, they are.
-Wow. What happened? When?
I didn't even know
they were teenagers.
-Yeah, time flew by.
-What's it like?
What are they like?
-They're great, and, you know,
but they're also
full of teenage angst,
and, you know, they're a little
grumpy at times.
-Yeah.
I have that to look forward to.
-Yeah, you're in
the sweet stage still.
-Yeah. You have a great family.
But, please, give them my best.
Like they care about me, but...
They're like, "I don't even know
who that guy is."
-No, no. They know you.
-Okay, good, good, good.
-They know you.
-I want to talk about
your movie.
This is called "Infinite Storm."
And this is based on
a true story.
And it's a wild story.
Can you set up what it's about?
-Yeah, it's about a woman
who's a search-and-rescue woman.
And she does the most incredible
rescue this particular time --
a man who's actually gone up to
the mountain to commit suicide.
-Yeah.
-And she risks her life.
She finds him in
literally short --
like as if he's dressed for the
beach, virtually.
And puts her own life at risk.
But what I love about
this film is,
it's not just a, you know,
high-drama film.
It's also --
There's a lot of poetry in it,
because nature is a
wonderful resource for healing.
She has her demons
that she's battling.
And -- Yeah, we always,
like, battle our demons
and we find other ways
for answers.
But, literally, the perfect
reminder in this film is that
nature is there
and it's beautiful
and it can quiet the mind.
You don't have to have
extreme settings like mountains,
but you can, you know,
just go to the river
or go to the beach or go to --
-The park or anything
and just get --
-And just quiet the mind.
-Yeah.
Did you know this story
before the script?
-I did not. I didn't.
-Yeah.
-But --
-It's wild.
She's doing her normal thing
and she sees these footprints
that go off the trail and she's
like -- in the snow --
and she's like,
"That's not normal."
-Yes, yeah.
-And then she --
-And they're sneakers.
They're not, like,
mountain boots, yeah.
And in this extreme weather
this particular day,
nobody should be out there
anyway, much less in sneakers.
-And she cares so much about
saving this --
It's a pretty fascinating story.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Naomi Watts in
"Infinite Storm."
Take a look.
-You belong to this...Pemige--
-Pemigewasset Search and Rescue.
Yeah, that's me, Pam Bales.
-You guys have a helicopter?
-What? A heli--
[ Laughs ] No, sir.
Just me.
No cellphone service till we get
to the parking lot either.
-No backup, either.
-Nope. It's just you and me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
Naomi, I saw that, recently,
you took up pottery.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
So -- And I was wondering if
you could maybe show me
how to make something
when we come back.
-Oh, yeah. Okay.
-Yeah, is that possible? Okay.
More with Naomi Watts
after the break.
Come on back.
We're making pottery!